he received a prize recently for the
coverage of the Queen's funeral since
those allegations came in and one of the
issues around this was the fact that he
had remained on air he had remained
working within the BBC whilst these
allegations were circulating he didn't
know about them until they came out in
the sun nor did the senior Executives
within the BBC and nor did the director
General and that's one of the things I
think the BBC will be looking at over
this but they will perhaps be relieved
in some respects that their processes
are not as badly under scrutiny as they
would have been if the police had come
out and said actually there is evidence
of criminal activity because then people
would have wondered why this hadn't been
pushed forward to the police sooner and
we have also got a statement from the
BBC with regards to the police saying
that there's no evidence of criminal
activity the BBC say we've seen the
statement from the police confirming
they have completed their assessment and
are not taking further action we're
grateful to them for completing this
work at speed the police had previously
he asked us to pause our fact-finding
investigations and we will now move
forward with that work ensuring the due
process and a thorough assessment of the
facts whilst continuing to be mindful of
our duty of care to all involved and of
course all the way through this the the
BBC have talked about duty of care It is
Well documented yeah Hugh Edwards has
talked about having bouts of depression
before what we've known that he's had
mental health issues but at the same
time he has been uh you know a real
presence on the BBC he's always looked
professional uh he's always really been
able to Anchor those key moments in our
history and that is why this is such a
big moment for the BBC that he has been
named his wife has come out and decided
to face the music but say that he's not
ready to talk about it because of his
condition because of his mental health
condition and he is being treated for
that and he but he is prepared to talk
about it when he when he's better so
that's what we've been told by the
family we've been told by the police
that there's no investigation at this
stage there's no evidence and I think we
saw that coming I think we could set we
could sense that when the individual
involved in the center of the Sun
article came out and said that the
stories that their parents were telling
were untrue and had said that in a
statement by a lawyer I think the fact
that the Sun newspaper hadn't provided
um evidence supporting the claims that
were being made by the parents and I
think that we'd heard also previously
from a police force that investigated
back in April that claims had been made
saying that they had not found no
evidence either so now the Met police
have looked at all the evidence and
they've said no criminality so that will
be a huge relief for Hugh Edwards no
doubt about that yeah um and look I know
Hugh Edwards and I know he's had these
depressive episodes and it is worth
pointing out that his wife
makes the point that he is getting
inpatient care uh at the moment
um so we've had this statement from the
uh police that will come as a huge
relief to
um Hugh Edwards no doubt but the BBC
investigation do we know the status of
of that
it continues so it it had never been
stopped until in fact the police took
over they say they say that they had
been trying to make contact with the
family who'd made the allegations but
they had only spoken to a senior manager
had spoken to Hugh Edwards once about
this
prior to then all the information going
to the police I don't think they'd had a
large number of uh time and
conversations to talk about it and also
of course there have been other
allegations that have come to light
since the police paused their
investigation not least from the BBC
themselves saying that uh Hugh Edwards
had been in touch with someone via a
dating app and then had made threatening
messages after that person had suggested
that they might go public over who he
was and then there's been these other
allegations by the Sun newspaper that he
had made a sent an inappropriate text
with 17 year old and also so that he had
gone to meet a young person during
lockdown in 2021 in February in the
third lockdown and that he had broken
the covid rules of that time and those
are much less serious allegations than
the one that was put in the Sun that was
suggested in the sun the sun has sort of
rode back a little bit on this
suggesting that really the thrust of
their articles that the BBC should have
properly investigated it
and certainly the BBC has admitted that
there they might have to look at their
flagging processes and stuff like that
when when things come in when when
complaints come into the BBC and they've
they've said that maybe not everything
that was done was done correctly and
they have given us this timeline of what
happened when that complaint first came
in on the 19th of May
But ultimately now they will be looking
at that they'll be looking back at you
know exactly what remaining allegations
there are from this particular family
that may not be criminal but may not
nonetheless be seen as inappropriate
they will look at the the relationship
and the way it panned out and they may
decide that it's a private matter or
they may decide uh that that it is a
disciplinary matter but that is for the
BBC now it does fall back into the hands
of of the BBC as to decide where they
take this investigation
yeah uh Jason uh for the moment thank
you very much uh so um Hugh Edwards is
the uh is named this evening as the
suspended BBC presenter it is a name uh
to be honest that's been flying around
social media for
um well several days now but we can now
report it as fact because of a statement
uh released this evening in the last few
minutes in fact by uh Vicki flind who is
the wife of Hugh Edwards and she says
in this statement uh this in light of
the recent reporting regarding
the BBC presenter I am making this
statement
on behalf of my husband Hugh Edwards
after what have been five extremely
difficult days for our family I'm doing
this primarily out of concern for his
mental well-being and to protect our
children
Hugh is suffering from serious mental
health issues as is well documented he
has been treated for severe depression
in recent years the events of the last
few days of greatly worsened matters he
has
suffered another serious episode and is
now receiving inpatient hospital care
where he'll stay for the foreseeable
future once well enough to do so he
intends to respond to the stories that
have been published to be clear Hugh was
first told that there were allegations
being made against him last Thursday
and she goes on in the circumstances and
given Hughes condition I would like to
ask that the privacy of my family and
everyone else caught up in these
upsetting events is respected I know
that Hugh is deeply sorry that so many
colleagues have been impacted by recent
media speculation we hope this statement
will bring that to an end
so there we are a dramatic statement
from the wife the man you see on your
screen there Hugh Edwards who is
revealed tonight as the BBC presenter
at the heart of all this and Jason
Farrell is with me and Jason it's
interesting that Vicki flind his wife
there says that you know once he is
better once he is able to he will
respond to these allegations and these
media stories
yes and and perhaps that also gives time
just for the BBC to make their own
investigations and inquiries and decide
just how serious this is
um I should perhaps just uh run you
through the what the BBC are saying
because of course now it does fall back
to them
um and they have said that they've seen
the statement from the police confirming
that they've completed their assessment
and are not taking further action so
we're grateful to them for completing
this work at speed and the police had
previously asked us to pause our
fact-finding investigation we'll now
move forward with that work ensuring due
process and thorough assessment of the
facts whilst continuing to be mindful of
of Duty of care to all involved but of
course you know there was a lot of
speculation around the BBC and whether
he should or should not come forward uh
and and explain and reveal himself from
a you know and break cover on this
because other presenters were the being
told on social media that was them they
were having to come out and deny it we
heard from Jeremy Vine yesterday on
Twitter basically saying I think maybe
he should consider coming out and naming
himself the BBC is on its knees Jeremy
Vine was saying
um he then had John sopel the ex-bbc man
saying shut up Jeremy Vine basically you
should you know he should decide himself
it's up to him whether or not he comes
out and how whether he plays the long
game or not so it was causing ructions
within the BBC from their major Stars uh
you know Nikki Campbell said he'd had a
terrible time from being hounded on
social media by people suggesting uh
that it was him Ryan Clark as it was
another who had to come out and say it
wasn't here but I'm sure they're all uh
you know all the famous names in it
within the BBC were were worried about
this uh you know Gary lineker their
highest paid star was was another the
one who'd had to come out and said it
wasn't him and but you know this is very
very high profile man if you look at
that um pay list that came out uh
yesterday I think he he's fourth on it
um and uh his salary had gone up
recently was talked yesterday in the
news only yesterday about his salary
going up because he because of course he
had been involved in so many uh
high-profile events recently with with
the funeral and the coronation and you
know being the voice of the nation
really for that for anyone watching uh
the BBC he's done the 2019 general
election he was really you know the
David dibbledy there will be replacement
he was he was taking over that real kind
of like senior senior role within the
BBC Beyond being the news at 10 reader
even but just you know absolutely major
events within the fabric of this country
uh he was the commentator he was the
voice that people would hear talking
about those very special events that
still impact on people's lives as well
as bringing the news for the last 20
years on the news at 10 and the last 30
years on the news on the six o'clock
last 30 years overall on on the main
Flagship programs because of course he
was on the six o'clock news before that
so really if you if talking about
longevity within the BBC there really
isn't anyone who's held such a high
profile role he is absolutely one of the
top faces you would think about on the
BBC and therefore you could see why
other people around him who are also in
those high profile positions were
thinking just please come out take the
pressure off us although it was quite
clear it to be fair that anyone who was
on air was clearly not that person
because
we all knew that that person had been
suspended so by the by the by the fact
that they were speaking into a
microphone meant it couldn't be them so
ultimately in a way that is how it
became so obvious who it was because of
course he should have been reading the
news this week and he wasn't and anyone
observing even you know half out of the
side of their eye would have noticed uh
that he was missing he was the big uh
big face of the BBC that was no longer
on the BBC so it it it was only a matter
of time before everybody knew about it
and pretty much as was said yesterday in
the interview with the director General
the BBC everyone within the building of
the BBC knew about it and they all had
varying opinions on whether he should or
shouldn't come out and face the music we
now know that he's been getting
treatment he needs some help
he's getting that help it is inpatient
treatment and he says by his wife his
wife says that he he does intend to face
down uh these these come out and talk
about these allegations and give his
view on what must be going on yeah I
mean the BBC's immediate concern will be
his well-being he's in inpatient care
now but then these allegations are still
around even though they don't weren't a
criminal investigation and we are
talking here as you say about the face
of the BBC's Authority the face of the
BBC's credibility
yeah and I think when you go back to
that original uh article in the Sun
newspaper one of the allegations was he
he was just too senior to investigate uh
that was pretty much the words of the
mother and that's how they felt because
of course they knew who it was and
although that person wasn't being named
in that Sun article that gave an
indication of what we were talking about
a high-profile presenter we couldn't say
at that time the most high profile news
presenter but that's that that was the
implication that that's why this hadn't
been properly investigated because
people were too afraid to to bring it up
and I think that is something that BBC
do have to look at they do have to look
at exactly how people responded to this
did they feel intimidated or worried
about going and talking to someone who
was right at the top of the BBC and
would that have been treated differently
if it was someone further down the
pecking order I I don't have the answer
to that I don't think anybody has the
answer to that yeah at but I think
that's one of the questions the BBC will
have to look at and I think the second
one is if it is a high profile person
you know there is greater responsibility
on that person because they are the face
of the organization so in those
instances is it acceptable that it takes
seven weeks for that person to realize
that an allegation like this has been
brought against them and or even the
director general or even any senior
Executives so that those are the
immediate questions that already spring
to light and I'm sure there are many
more
Jason uh thank you very much
indeed for that let me just repeat this
statement that has come in tonight from
the wife of uh Hugh Edwards Vicki flind
and she says this in the light of recent
reporting regarding the quotes BBC
presenter I am making this statement on
behalf of my husband Hugh Edwards after
what have been five extremely difficult
days for our family I am doing this
primarily out of concern for his mental
well-being and to protect our children
Hugh is suffering from serious mental
health issues as is well documented he
has been treated for severe depression
in recent years the events of the last
few days have greatly worsened matters
he has suffered another serious episode
and is now receiving inpatient hospital
care where he'll stay for the
foreseeable future once well enough to
do so she says he intends to respond to
the stories that have been published to
be clear Hugh was first told that there
were allegations being made against him
last Thursday in the circumstances and
given Hugh's condition I would like to
ask that the privacy of my family and
everyone else caught up in these ups
setting events is respected
and she adds I know that Hugh is deeply
sorry that so many colleagues have been
impacted by the recent media speculation
we hope this statement will bring that
to an end
let's speak now to uh Katie Spencer who
has also been following uh this story so
Katie in the event it is the wife of the
BBC presenter who has uh named him it is
the wife of uh Hugh Edwards
really of um just a terrific amount of
pressure Hugh Edwards has been under
over the past few days
um we get that from the fact that his
wife is having to put this statement out
do you have to be perfect to be in the
public eye no absolutely not but but for
some people who are in certain roles
Behavior matters more than others and
now we know can publicly say Hugh
Edward's name on air that is the reason
I think so many people have been Keen
for it to be clearer for it to his name
to to be out there and explained given
the context of this because of course
Hugh Edwards
one of the finest News broadcasters in
this country one of the most
recognizable faces in in broadcasting
covering some of the biggest news
stories in the world
um and during covid playing a pivotal
role in that and of course we know
within the last 24 hours one of the
allegations that has been made against
him is that uh as he was publicly on a
nightly basis explaining the latest
developments on the the pandemic
criticizing people like uh announcing
stories criticizing people like Dominic
Cummings at the same time we now have
this claim from uh uh published in the
sun today from a person that he
allegedly met on a a dating app who said
that he was encouraged trying to
encourage this young person to break the
rules and they did eventually uh meet up
as he traveled to meet this person at
their house
um so I think that's why it has become
more relevant because of the role that
he had this public facing and the
requirement it is as him being a news
anchor to to be critical of other people
and also aware of how his own behavior
impacts on the corporation and on the
work that he does
I I mean he he is just a brilliant
broadcaster there is no doubt of that
but it had become just absolutely
untenable this situation he couldn't
carry on uh as he was everyone within uh
the building the new broadcasting house
was aware of exactly who the person in
question was there was no getting away
from this and I think clearly his family
have recognized that it was important
for you actually just to address it to
address this and and stop the stress on
Hugh himself now it is um it's quite an
upsetting statement really from his wife
isn't it to hear that again the impact
that it has had on his mental health and
he has spoken really of a 20-year
struggle that he has had with depression
while we all know him for his
professionalism how how witty he is how
sharp changed he is he has uh within the
last Euro so it really opened up about
the struggle that he's had with
depression over the past 20 years uh
talking about um how far has been so bad
at times he hasn't been able to get out
of bed and I think
um yeah clearly this has been a huge
huge event within his life and it it has
taken its toll on his mental health yeah
Katie thank you very much let's speak
now to former BBC executive Tim
luckhurst who uh joins us uh Tim good
evening uh thank you for being with us
so
um named by his wife Hugh Edwards one of
the best and best known news anchors in
the country
yes and I knew you well when I worked at
the BBC when I worked on today program
he was one of the kindest most reliable
most inspirational colleagues that I've
ever had the pleasure to work with and
I'm absolutely stunned by the news of
course I've been aware that this was the
name in the frame for a long time but
the exact details are truly upsetting
Hugh Edwards has done a great deal for
the BBC he's done a great deal for
broadcasting in this country and to find
him in this position is really quite
shocking and I feel very very sorry for
Hugh and for his family
yeah I'm the statement from his wife was
preceded by this statement from the
Metropolitan Police saying that there
was no information at the moment that
they have that weren't say criminal
investigation which no doubt will come
as a huge relief to Hugh Edwards but
there is then the BBC investigation and
one wonders you know where the BBC go
with this from here
well I think that the absence of
evidence to justify criminal
investigation is very significant
because with the facts in this case are
yet to be known and we still have a
great deal to find out before we can be
quite clear about what has actually
happened but if there's been no
criminality then there have to be
questions asked about what kind of
pressure Hugh Edwards may have been put
under by those with whom he'd been in
contact there have always been two sides
to this story we've seen one side Curtis
and son and I make no criticism of the
Sun for its reporting which has
genuinely set the agenda it's a very
fine popular newspaper and it's been
doing its job well but we haven't heard
Hugh Edward's side of this story given
Hugh Edwards is in hospital and his
family want peace I suspect we're going
to wait some time to hear that but
hopefully the BBC will get to the bottom
of this and we'll get to the bottom of
it with the rigor and with the degree of
speed that would be truly helpful yeah
but it may take time given
um his the condition of his mental
health as described and as outlined in
this statement by his wife
it may take time I hope that it takes
less time than it might the simple truth
is that there are people who can be
questioned there are processes which can
be examined there are individuals who
can be challenged on this and I hope
that the BBC will go about that process
diligently and fairly of course there
are accounts from both sides of the
story that may well be wrongdoing on
Hughes part I think that that is
something we have to bear very firmly in
mind but it's equally possible that
there has been wrongdoing on other sides
as well and the possibility that people
have been trying to take advantage of
the fact that a person public eye a very
high profile public figure may have been
in touch with them in his private life
in a way which would be embarrassing for
the public for him for the public to
know I do not know that but certainly I
understand how vulnerable someone in
Hugh Edward's position can be in
circumstances when they can be faced by
up people making allegations which in
other cases might be regarded as trivial
or indeed simply as threatening and just
finally Tim um the sun's position in all
this it was their original story
um and I suppose they would argue that
just because there is no criminal
uh you know investigation by the police
doesn't mean that they shouldn't have
run the story I guess that will be their
argument
I would not criticize the son for
running the story not for a second the
sun is a great popular newspaper it was
brought a story by parents who are
making a serious complaint about the
behavior of a BBC star and the son has
listened to that and I'm sure done the
checks that it normally does and it does
those checks very well it is a newspaper
with a great deal of editorial
experience this is a tragic story but
that doesn't mean it make it wrong for
the sun to publish it journalism is
about truth it's not about sympathy
sadly
Tim thank you very much indeed
appreciate your time thank you thank you
let's just uh repeat the statement we
have tonight and the reason that uh the
uh Hugh Edwards is the face on your
screen right now is because his wife
Vicki Flynn has released a statement uh
and it says this in the light of recent
reporting regarding the BBC presenter I
am making this statement on behalf of my
husband Hugh Edwards after what have
been five extremely difficult days for
our family I am doing this primarily out
of concern for his mental well-being and
to protect our children he was suffering
from serious mental health issues as is
well documented he has been treated for
severe depression in recent years the
events of the last few days have greatly
worsened matters he has suffered another
serious episode and is now receiving
inpatient hospital care where he'll stay
for the foreseeable future
she goes on once well enough to do so he
intends to respond to the stories that
have been published to be clear Hugh was
first told that there were allegations
being made against him last Thursday in
the circumstances and given Hugh's
condition I would like to ask the
privacy of my family and everyone else
caught up in these upsetting events is
respected I know that Hugh is deeply
sorry that so many colleagues have been
impacted by recent media speculation we
hope this statement will bring that to
an end
let's go back then to our home editor
Jason Farrell so Jason as I was saying
this name has been flying around social
media for the last few days now it is
confirmed by his wife that it is Hugh
Edwards and one of the most senior
broadcasters in this country I think
doing the BBC six o'clock news since 94
I think and then News at 10 for many
years and also all these State occasions
in many ways the face of the BBC
yeah that's right I mean he did uh
Prince William's wedding he did Prince
Harry's wedding he did the Queen's
funeral he did the Queen's husband's
funeral he did the coronation
um since the allegations came through he
also
did the birthday celebrations for the
new king he picked up an award a trick
award which is a TV industry award for
the coverage that the BBC did of the
Queen's State funeral
and he was the face of the BBC no doubt
about that and um as you say he'd read
the news for over 30 years for the BBC
and for 20 years of that the flagship
News at 10 and he read the news with
great Authority he was well regarded
well respected presenter and journalist
within the industry and that is why this
has really flooded the media for the
last five days because it's pretty much
been known for some time that this is
the person we've been talking about the
person that we've not been able to name
couldn't have loomed more large in this
story and at some point it always seemed
inevitable that his name would come out
Simply by the fact that it was such a
big name the allegations were serious
but I think you know we've been talking
about this now for the last sort of 45
minutes and it started with as almost as
big a revelation in this story The the
that actually the criminal allegations
had not been found to be evidenced by
the Met police I think it's no
coincidence that these statements come
out almost on top of each other so in
fact I'm just going to remind people of
what the Met police have said in their
statement because that is significant as
well as the revealing of who it is so
they say detectives from The Specialist
crime command have now concluded their
assessment and have determined there is
no information Nation to indicate that a
criminal offense has been committed in
reaching this decision they have spoken
to a number of parties including the BBC
and the alleged complainant and the
alleged complainants family let's not
forget both those two parties differed
so the complainant the alleged
complainant was saying it was all untrue
uh the plaintiff's family said it was
true but both via another police force
there's no further police action as such
the Met has advised the BBC it can
continue with its internal investigation
we are aware of media reporting of
further allegations against the same
individual no specific details or
information about these allegations have
been passed to us and therefore there is
no police action at this time and
obviously those details are the uh the
suggestion in the Sun newspaper that he
broke lock down rules to go and meet
someone and also Suggestions by the BBC
which they say they do have evidence of
because they say a link to his phone
that he sent threatening messages to
someone who he met in a dating app so
whether the BBC will provide that feel
that that's criminal uh that you know
you there there are uh criminalities
around messaging such as a malicious
communication crimes that you know they
it might cross that threshold it might
not we haven't seen those messages so we
don't know
um but the police do go on to say that
should evidence of criminality or
safeguarding issues be identified at any
point we would expect matters to be
referred to the relevant police force I
think we could also now safely say that
the police force that they had
originally been looking at this back in
April was in Wales we were obviously not
saying that because that might have
identified the presenter but it was a
Welsh police force that were looking
into
the uh the original allegations that
were made in April and they had also
found no criminality so that's where
we're up to now in terms of the
allegations they go back to the BBC to
do their own internal investigations not
around criminality but over whether
anything was done inappropriately
anything that might bring the
organization into distribute anything
that might lead to disciplinary action
against Hugh Edwards uh for his Prof you
know that that may not look good with
his position within the company
okay Jason uh thank you very much indeed
uh we're joined Now by Mark Bukowski
media industry commentator PR branding
uh expert Mark we've spoken
um I think twice during this and uh
um we've been talking about the unnamed
BBC presenter where we now know
um it is you know the face of the BBC uh
Hugh Edwards what are your thoughts
well my thoughts are that um I I suspect
that there was a sort of change in the
mood in social media today I just think
there was a huge amount of empathy
because people are still sort of playing
around with with commentary on the fact
they didn't know the story they didn't
know the identity and I think that that
a change where people began to think
well there's something more to this and
a huge amount of feeling for for the
family or whoever that person was and
clearly that was here so it's quite
interesting that I think things are
moving into more compassionate sort of
place so I think that the family have
taken
um the decision now to empower
themselves with actually Lancing the
ball whatever the expression you want to
to to actually identify and I think that
Jeremy Vine in particular who are
calling out for
um the person to be named I think we we
clearly are now beginning to see that
there are some other issues
um involved with someone who is the rock
of the BBC that the face of all those
um big moments the nation's anchor for
the BBC uh underneath or there's
something else going on and maybe the
story around wine now we can have a
proper critique and a proper insight
into the real stories now you know there
was a very powerful um uh Channel 4
documentary that um who had was a few
years ago talking about the demons he
was struggling with and for me it just
emphasizes that you if you carry that
burden of Fame and there are other
issues going on in your private life
it's incredibly toxic and I suspect that
that's been at the root of this but
there's no criminality so what people do
in private is is totally in their power
and it's it might be interesting for the
public but it's not of public interest
no and look I know Hugh Edwards and that
he's discussed these depressive episodes
with me and that's the reason he took
days off work and he has taken days off
work but the fact remains Mark that
these allegations uh exist and the BBC
investigation still exists I assume that
with with uh Hugh Edwards getting in
patient care this will now be pushed
back and delayed somewhat
well it gives everybody the time and
space to evaluate what they're going to
do next
um because they you know that the BBC
and and most of the people perhaps on
Hugh Edward's side of the fence have
sort of been driven by the 21st century
social media
um sort of Demands and of course you
know you know due process and the way
that um maybe some of the glacial
institutions have to move is is not a
kilter with what social media demands so
maybe this is a leveling off of of a
position on this at the moment maybe
people start looking themselves and stop
jumping to conclusions and Fielding the
gossip Mill but it is a if the man is
obviously in care
um and he has you know has a history of
mental health issue you know one has to
worry about him you know let's not
forget you know Caroline Flack uh the
pressures of celebrity is is difficult
for people who are who have to carry
that burden so
um as I said weeks will go by I suspect
to to dampen the flames I think
questions will be asked and continue
about the BBC's process I mean yesterday
Tim Davey declaring that he had not
spoken to the principal in the matter
that was who who Edwards and that's
incredible to think that this the key
person
um in your organization who fronts some
of the big public events the DG didn't
speak to it I I think that's got to be
embarrassing
um for him um and it shows sort of
layers of decision making that exist in
an organization like BBC who have been
battered
um with scandals and this is is quite a
quite a blow and so the BBC are going to
have to look at their own procedures and
if there were
um people you know drawing the BBC
um to the attentions of the activities
that were all together legal it would
seem but um questionable and they
haven't dealt with it I think there's
there's there's going to be some red
faces and some embarrassed people and I
don't know how many you know battering
moments the BBC can take but this isn't
this is this is a really really powerful
day
um with with more stories pinging off
that but I think everybody is now
showing great empathy for someone who
clearly is not well yeah and we're going
to bring Harvey Proctor in a moment
wrongly accused uh in 2015. I get his
take but I just just wanted to ask you I
mean the the BBC now have this balance
to have to balance this duty of care to
um one of its employees with the need to
to do this investigation I just wonder
too early to say what what happens now
to Hugh Edwards in his career I assume
oh gosh yes
um I think it's far too early
um to say that and so there has to be a
duty of care
um and this is a problem the BBC the BBC
is still an organization that is still
trying to get its way out of 20th
century practices where the rest of the
world particularly in television
streamers 24 news Cycles or whatever in
very much in the hands of the 21st
century and uh they they're Paralyzed by
this at the moment and there's got to be
some deep changes I would think in the
quality of decision making to look at
these things I mean departmentally
um to make this but for Hugh Edwards I
no one has an idea at least now we can
have a a recent debate and one hopes
that the sort of the nasty sort of
Twitter Arty the crowd that I've sort of
harvested you know so much content on
this and um you know being so brutal or
maybe give some thought at the moment to
stand back really and take take a breath
okay Mark appreciate your time thanks
very much indeed we have a little bit of
breaking news from the BBC and the BBC
uh spokesperson has said we have seen
the statement from the police confirming
they have completed their assessment and
are not taking further action uh we're
grateful to them for completing this
work at speed the police had previously
asked us to pause our fact-finding
investigations and we will now move
forward with that work ensuring due
process and a thorough assessment of the
facts whilst continuing to be mindful of
our duty of care to all involved
um and I'm told we've got a statement
also from South Wales police and that
says that South Wales police has
remained in contact with representatives
of the Metropolitan Police and the BBC
following a meeting on Monday
information was initially received
by the force in April 2023 regarding the
welfare of an adult no criminality was
identified following recent events
further inquiries have been carried out
and officers have spoken to a number of
parties to establish whether any
criminal allegations are being made at
this time there is no evidence that any
criminal offenses have been committed
there are no ongoing inquiries being
carried out by South Wales police
let's talk now to a former conservative
MP Harvey Proctor
um he agreed a settlement with the Met
police after being falsely accused of
child abuse and murder Harvey uh good
evening to you and I think I'm writing
saying you were going to come on to
argue that uh
you know he shouldn't necessarily be
named in the current circumstances or
the circumstances that to pertain before
the police statement and before his wife
then decided that the way to do this was
to issue a statement to say it was her
husband what do you make of these events
this evening
I despair of the media
I despair of the BBC and input
icular the other senior presenters of
the BBC
who was so selfish
only caring for themselves
and not for the innocent person at the
center of this issue
I think at the outset all our thoughts
should be with Mr Edwards
his wife
and children
they will have gone through hell
in the last few days
and that hell has been stoked up
by their former colleagues his former
colleagues at the BBC
this is a an innocent man
falsely accused
of a number of things and I think the
BBC
should in their duty of care
close their investigation well they
they've the the police have said there
are no there's no evidence of
criminality but the allegations but at
least
said no but just said by the saying that
there are still allegations out there
that may not amount to criminality but
they they surely have to be looked at no
I haven't come I haven't come on Sky
News
to uh be party to further allegations
against Mr Edwards certainly not I made
that quite clear now you must stop this
stop it now no no before you have a
death on your hands no no I'm just
making the point that they're not
allegations we are making
and that the BBC is
and the BBC are going to investigate it
now
Sky News have a responsibility to this
man's life as the BBC have so stop it
let's all concentrate on making sure
that our love and care and affection is
for the man his wife his family and his
children nothing else so I know because
I've been for this well so on that point
you were falsely accused and not helped
when the police described the
allegations as credible and true in your
case not helped by that at all just
Describe the impact all that had on you
I don't want to go over what happened to
me in detail but I do know the horrors
that Mr Edwards and his family have been
experiencing recent days and I don't
want to pile any more pressure or hurt
upon him and his family nor do I think
anyone else in the media should do so
he is in hospital
he is not personally able to speak for
himself
I'm sure a time will come when if he
wishes and he should not be forced then
he will respond but not now now is the
time to respect him
and what he's done for the BBC in the
past
his wife yeah who is stuck by him
his family and his children
nothing else okay
um Harvey Proctor appreciate you coming
on this evening to make your points
thank you very much indeed
we're joined Now by Jake Cantor the
media correspondent of the times good
evening Jake thank you for uh being with
us I just wonder what you make of the
developments this evening
good evening Mark I mean well look this
ends days of wild and defamatory
speculation on social media I think it
was inevitable
uh that he was going to be named at some
point and it was increasingly clear that
that identification was most likely
going to come from him or someone who
knew him and right now we have
confirmation from Vicki Flynn his wife
and it's clear that
um the recent days have been very
traumatic for Hugh Edwards and for his
family and I think it's important to
remember that we are talking about a
family here and they will all be
impacted by this crisis
um but yeah an inevitability and
um a real bombshell Hugh Edwards is
uh the BBC's highest paid news anchor he
is
um uh arguably at the peak of his powers
uh he has come off the back of a year in
which he has uh beluded for presenting
the BBC's coverage of the Queen's death
and uh the coronation and
um you know the BBC now has to do its
own investigation into his alleged
conduct yeah well the statement from his
wife talks about
um Hugh Edwards being in inpatient Care
at the moment and he's had these
depressive episodes that uh we've talked
about I just wonder it's all very
difficult and delicate now for the BBC
balancing this you know duty of care
with the investigation just had the
statement they intend to continue it's a
how do you think the BBC
need to play this going forward and I I
apologize me I said you were the times
didn't I your deadline I just need to
correct correct that but yeah I used to
work at the time I apologize it's okay I
apologize how did the BBC do this going
forward
Well they
um they're going to have to be really
careful and we've seen that in the tenor
of some of their statements in recent
days they've kind of hinted at what we
now know in terms of Hugh edwards's
state of mind and they've talked about
duty of care they've talked about
proceeding carefully and rapidly
um and look they are going to have to be
you know
both weighing up their responsibility to
him as an individual but also the
responsibility to license fee Pairs and
to those who have made allegations
against him and that's going to be a
tricky Balancing Act and I think the BBC
will take time I hope
um it will consider the allegations in
the fall we are obviously seeing other
allegations being made against Hugh
Edwards whether those will be part of
the investigation it's not entirely
clear right now but we are we're on a
bit of an information pre-zone about how
the BBC is going to proceed we may hear
more over the coming days okay Jake
thank you very much for coming on and
appreciate your time I have a tweet from
uh John sopel former BBC colleague of
Hugh Edwards and he has said this is an
awful and shocking episode where there
was no criminality but perhaps a
complicated private life that doesn't
feel very private now I hope that will
give some cause to reflect they really
need to I wish Hugh Edwards well that
from John sopel who was a colleague of
his at the BBC and all this after the
wife of the news reader Hugh Edwards
said he is suffering from serious mental
health issues and receiving inpatient
hospital care as uh she named him her
husband
BBC anchor Hugh Edwards as the man
facing allegations overpayments for
sexually explicit images the police say
there is no evidence or that determine
or need a criminal investigation but the
BBC say their investigation goes on more
at the top of the hour
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
it is seven o'clock this is Sky News
Tonight our top story the wife of the
BBC presenter Hugh Edwards names him as
the man at the center of the allegations
of the plunge the corporation into
crisis
in a statement Vicky Flynn's Hugh
Edward's wife says that the star is
suffering from serious mental health
issues
it comes as the Metropolitan Police at
South Wales police say that no criminal
offense has been committed and that the
BBC can now conclude their own internal
investigation
we will be live at new broadcasting
house since Central London the
headquarters of the BBC for the very
latest and we'll ask a former BBC
journalist what now Mr Edwards and for
the corporation itself
[Music]
good evening our top story Hugh Edwards
has been named as the BBC presenter at
the center of a days long media frenzy
the star the highest paid journalist at
the BBC has been named by his wife in a
statement that she issued on his behalf
she says he's suffering from serious
mental health issues and has appealed
for privacy for him and for the family
now here is the statement from Vicky
Flint the wife of Hugh Edwards in full
it reads in the light of recent
reporting regarding the BBC presenter I
am making this statement on behalf of my
husband Hugh Edwards after what have
been five extremely difficult days for
our family
I'm doing this primarily out of concern
for his mental well-being and to protect
our children Hugh is suffering from
serious mental health issues
as is well documented he's been treated
for severe depression in recent years
the events of the last few days have
greatly worsened matters he has suffered
another serious episode and is now
receiving inpatient hospital care where
he will stay for the foreseeable future
once well enough to do so he intends to
respond to the stories that have been
published to be clear he was first told
that there were allegations being made
against him last Thursday
and the circumstances and given Hughes
condition I would like to ask that the
privacy of my family and everyone else
caught up in these upsetting events is
respected
I know that Hugh is deeply sorry that so
many colleagues have been impacted by
the recent media speculation we hope
this statement will bring that to an end
right let me just take you through how
we reached this point over the weekend
the Sun newspaper claimed that the
presenter paid an individual 35
000 pounds for sexually explicit images
over a period dating back to 2020.
yesterday it was reported by the BBC
that a second person was sent what was
described as abusive and expletive
filled messages after an interaction
with the presenter on social media
today's Sun alleges that the presenter
broke lockdown rules with another
individual in February of 2021 and again
the Sun have claimed another individual
says that Edward sent them creepy
messages on Instagram when that person
was 17.
now the naming of Hugh Edwards comes as
the Metropolitan Police say they're
taking no further action against a
presenter in a statement the force said
detectives from the Mets specialist
crime command have now concluded their
assessment and have determined there is
no information to indicate that a
criminal offense has been committed
in reaching this decision they've spoken
to a number of parties including the BBC
and the alleged complainant and the
alleged complainants family both via
another police force
there's no further police action as such
the Met has advised the BBC that it can
continue with its internal investigation
and they conclude we are aware of media
reporting of further allegations against
the same individual no specific details
or information about these allegations
have been passed to us and therefore
there's no police action at this time
should evidence of criminality or
safeguarding issues be identified at any
point we would expect matters to be
referred to the relevant police force
let's bring in azadia charger who's
outside new Broadcasting House in
central London so Saudia the last star
of course Hugh Edwards has been named by
his wife take us through the reaction
that there's been now from the BBC
look Hugh Edwards is a man whose voice
is as Flagship as the program he
produces and tonight BBC News at 10 will
not just be missing its usual presenter
it will have to No Doubt make him the
top story and what a complex story that
is and how difficult it must be for
people here at the BBC to have to tell
it because they have the last few days
remained very tight-lipped about uh who
he is we were told yesterday that
everyone at the BBC essentially knew who
it was but they weren't able to say so
and now they have to tell this story and
it is of course very complex because
we've heard tonight that this is a man
who is suffering his wife says with
serious mental health issues she said
he's in hospital and he's likely to
remain there for some time but of course
if anyone at home is thinking this is
just an excuse it probably isn't because
he would resist someone who has public
actually spoken about his depression and
we know that he is someone who has
previously had severe depression it is
very difficult for people here at the
BBC to now come to terms perhaps
publicly about this it is something that
for for the last few days they've had to
remain tight-lipped about there's been a
lot of support for him but also a lot of
pressure on him from colleagues and
former colleagues today John sopor one
of his former colleagues who was who's
also used to work at BBC news said that
he thinks this is a really difficult
circumstance
um he said there's no criminality here
but it looks like the com really
complicated private life and a reminder
that there are those allegations against
Hugh Edwards but no criminality there
has been found he is one of the most
recognizable faces in broadcasting so
one who started his career in 1984 he
presented the BBC News at six the six
o'clock news and then the flagship 10
o'clock news which he's been presenting
for a while he's covered some of the
biggest stories that this nation has
seen in fact of the world he covered the
Queen's funeral and most notably last
year and the coronation of King Charles
he's
universally liked I think he's known for
his professionalism and his sharp wit
he's someone whose voice is one of those
trusted voices on the BBC and he's very
much been very private about his
personal life not much is known about
his personal life but as I say
his struggles with mental health have
been publicly discussed he's been open
about that and tonight his wife has
talked about how he has
um he is she says suffering with mental
health issues he has done previously
with severe depression and that he's in
hospital but just to put this all in
context this all started of course with
these allegations firstly in the Sun
newspaper over the weekend where the Sun
newspaper reported that a mother had
come forward to
say that a BBC TV presenter who they
didn't name at the time
had paid her son or daughter when they
were 17 up to 35
000 pounds for sexually explicit images
of themselves and that then led to a
whole weekend of coverage lots of
speculation
on online about who this presenter might
be some of Hugh Edward's colleagues then
felt under pressure to come out and say
that it's not them because of the sheer
amount of online abuse that they were
receiving and yesterday Jeremy Vine one
of those presenters said that he thought
Hugh Edwards should come out and
publicly say who he is just because
of all of all of the online abuse that
he was receiving it is not an easy time
surely at the BBC with so much that has
happened in the last few hours
let's go to a commercial
so um just to reiterate you to you that
we're here he's the most trusted voice
in BBC News it is shocking development
for people
um outside of the BBC we were told of
course yesterday that there was uh that
people at the BBC everyone here knew we
remember when Tim Davey the director
General did that interview on Radio 4 he
spoke about he was it was put to him
that everybody at the BBC knew who it
was and yet uh it wasn't being it we
weren't hearing the name publicly
tonight in a really shocking development
Hugh Edward's wife has come out with
this statement in which she says that he
has he is suffering with mental health
illnesses I'll read out to you this um
the statement from Vicky Flynn the wife
of Hugh Edwards she says in light of the
recent reporting regarding the BBC
presenter I am making the statement on
behalf of my husband Hugh Edwards after
what have been five extremely difficult
days for our family I'm doing this
primarily out of concern for his mental
well-being and to protect our children
he was suffering from serious mental
health issues as is well documented he
has been treated for severe depression
in recent years the events of the last
few days have greatly worsened matters
he has suffered another serious episode
and is now receiving inpatient hospital
care where he'll stay for the
foreseeable future she continues once
we're well enough to do so he intends to
respond to the stories that have been
published to be clear he was first told
that there were allegations being made
against him last Thursday in the
circumstances and given Hughes condition
I'd like to ask that the privacy of my
family and everyone else caught up in
these upsetting events is respected she
ends saying I know that he was deeply
sorry that so many colleagues have been
impacted by the recent media speculation
we hope this statement will bring an end
to that and it was some of those
colleagues who spoke out very openly
over the weekend and in the last few
days about the amount of abuse that
they'd received Online for being
mistaken to be the presenter at the
center of this we know that Nikki
Campbell said it was so bad for him that
he had to he had to speak to his lawyers
and get the police involved and Jeremy
Vine last night with that tweet urging
what we now know Hugh Edwards to come
forward saying that it is not just to
protect his purely innocent colleagues
but also
in respect to the BBC which he said was
being damaged he described the BBC as
having been being brought to its knees
over this certainly we've seen in the
last few days the scramble at the BBC
first of all to try and explain what
happened there was a short delay in even
explaining it with the timetable of what
what happened and when being released
just yesterday and we we learned from
that that allegations were made first
against Hugh Edwards
um sometime
in May around May 18th and the next day
BBC had escalated that to their
corporate investigations team which
followed that up with a phone with an
email a bigger pardon to the complainant
but then we were told that in in this
timeline that was outlined to us that
there was no response to that email so
they waited a few weeks and then tried a
phone call that phone call didn't
connect
um and it it took the family originally
making this complaint to go to the Sun
newspaper before the sun contacted the
BBC press office and that's when the BBC
really escalated it and that was
criticized so it is something that has
caused turmoil here at the BDC with the
director General having to face lots of
questions during a press conference that
should have been about the corporation's
accounts ended up being dominated by
this but at the center of this have been
those allegations and how difficult it
must now be for the BBC to continue this
investigation which they had paused now
they have to resume it but knowing that
that duty of care they had by on not
naming their presenter now extends to a
presenter who is according to his wife
suffering with serious mental health
issues
thank you very much indeed now if you
were expecting to hear kamali's voice
there's actually just been a fire alarm
so I'm going to be guiding you through
the coverage for now good evening well
as you know our top story Hugh Edwards
is named as the BBC presenter at the
center of a days long media frenzy well
the star the highest paid journalist at
the BBC has been named by his wife in a
statement that she issued on his behalf
she says that he is suffering from
serious mental health issues and has
appealed for privacy both for him and
the family
well let's take you through the
statement now from Vicki flind in full
she says in light of the recent
reporting regarding the BBC presenter
I'm making the statement on behalf of my
husband Hugh Edwards after what have
been five extremely difficult days for
our family I'm doing this primarily out
of concern for his mental well-being and
to protect our children
he was suffering from serious mental
health issues as is well documented he's
been treated for severe depression in
recent years
the events the last few days have
greatly worsened matters he suffered
another serious episode and is now
receiving impatient hospital care where
he will stay for the foreseeable future
once well enough to do so he intends to
respond to the stories that have been
published and she goes on to say to be
clear he was first told that there were
allegations being made against him last
Thursday in the circumstances and given
Hugh's condition I would like to ask
that the privacy of my family and
everyone else caught up in these
upsetting events is respected I know
that Hugh is deeply sorry that so many
colleagues have been impacted by the
recent media speculation we hope the
statement will bring that to an end
so that statement there issued by the
wife of Hugh Edwards that's Vicki
Flynn's
um responding to the allegations and
naming Hugh Edwards as the presenter
suspended by the BBC
well let me take you through how we
reach this point now over the weekend
the sun claimed that the presenter paid
in an individual 35 000 pounds for
sexually explicit images over a period
dating back to 2020. well yesterday it
was reported by the BBC that a second
person was sent what were described as
abusive and expletive filled messages
after an interaction with the presenter
on social media and today's edition of
The Sun Also alleges the presenter broke
lockdown rules with another individual
that was in February 2021 and again the
sun had claimed another individual says
that Hugh Edward sent them what they
described as creepy messages on
Instagram when they were 17 years old
so that's the timeline of events there
the naming a few Edwards comes as the
Metropolitan Police say that they are
taking no further action against the
presenter in a statement the force says
detectives from the Met specialist crime
command have now concluded their
assessments and they've determined that
there is no information to indicate that
a criminal offense has been committed in
reaching this decision they've spoken to
a number of parties including the BBC
and the alleged complainant and the
alleged complainments family both by
another police force there is no further
police action as such the mets has
advised the BBC it can continue with its
internal investigation we are aware of
media reporting of further allegations
against the same individual no specific
details or information about these
allegations have been passed to us and
therefore there is no police action at
this time should evidence of criminality
or safeguarding issues be identified at
any point we would expect matters to be
referred to the relevant police force
that statement thereby the Met police
saying that there'll be no further
action taken at this time against Hugh
Edwards and of course what this does
mean is that the BBC can continue with
their own investigation which was on
hold until the police carried out their
own inquiries
well we can speak now to David elstein
who is a former chief executive of
Channel 5 and a former BBC producer
do you think it was inevitable that this
name was going to come out
yes I think it's been a lot of people
knew the name yesterday and certainly
most people in the BBC did and it was uh
only amount of time and every sympathy
with uh Hugh edwards's wife Vicky Flynn
and her very dignified statement uh it's
extremely hard when you're under severe
media pressure
uh to uh act in a way which is
um both properly uh informative and
dignified and I think that is what she's
done and
Hughes uh issues with mental health have
been well known for many years his
problems with depression now we know
that uh he's got other behavioral issues
the police tell us that there's nothing
criminal involved to be honest I'm not
the faintest idea what a BBC
investigation is meant to be I had no
idea until recently there was such a
thing as a BBC investigations unit
sounds pretty uh Sinister to me but
um hopefully that will all now be uh
quickly closed down and uh Hugh will be
allowed to recover uh his health and
once he is back to full health no doubt
he and Tim Davis at the BBC will discuss
what if any his future of the BBC will
be
you say that you think the idea of a BBC
investigations unit is Sinister I just
wondered if I could unpick that a bit um
some would say isn't it right that the
BBC has a process where if you have a
concern about a public figure someone's
paid for by the taxpayer that you should
be able to
complain about that and raise your
concerns
and one of the BBC managers do
investigate
well yesterday a guardian journalist was
saying they should inspect his phone I
mean you know what are we living in
Romania you think just to come in though
I mean you would think maybe they'll go
and talk to him that would be the first
step wouldn't it in an investigation
no because if
if Point
listen
the original allegations uh
whoever it was who heard the complaint
um
it was told that the police had refused
to get involved so what would the BBC do
um hold a criminal investigation itself
I just don't I'd never know of any
broadcaster with an internal
investigations unit uh it's uh you know
it's the Stars here broadcasting house
uh in the 1950s the BBC had uh a
connection with special branch in which
anyone who was thought to have left-wing
views a little Christmas tree attached
to their personal file as that they
wouldn't be promoted too high within the
BBC but this is on another level and I'm
uh I would hope that the first thing
that Tim Davey does is shut this unit
down is the only bar criminal though
obviously if you if you've got people
fiddling their expenses the finance
department will be onto them and then
the legal department will be onto them
but at the BBC he rightly has
investigative journalists but the notion
that it has a dedicated unit
investigating its own staff's behavior
you know that's the uh invasion of
privacy issue that I would be concerned
about uh in all of this uh it's wrong
and it shouldn't be happening and I hope
that nobody takes this so-called
investigation uh any further do you
think that Hugh Edwards should keep his
job then
it's possible uh you know uh we all have
um difficulties in life we go through
phases of uh of being over stressed you
know Federal Keynes explained his mental
health issues a number of broadcasters
especially those exposed to uh high
pressure situations War zones and so
forth uh take months off work and then
come back now obviously uh if Hugh
Edwards wants to come back to BBC uh
especially uh in so prominental roles is
currently uh been occupied he will need
to have a very Frank talk with Tim Davey
and the uh at the news Department uh
Senior Management
to establish the parameters of what he
should or shouldn't be doing and by then
we will know exactly what was involved
here
um so
um you know in my view uh
there's there's no inherent bar to him
returning to work it may be that he
prefers to return if he returns at all
to a lower profile drop
look at the statement from Vicki Flynn's
Hugh Edward's wife as you say a very
dignified statement she says that he was
suffering from serious mental health
issues and that the events the last few
days of worst matters she goes on to say
that he's now receiving inpatient
hospital care where he'll stay for this
foreseeable future
do you feel sorry for him
immensely I mean his obviously had a lot
of different is his
you know the expression of his problems
has
gone down some strange Roots by the
sound of things uh and his engagements
uh online uh with third parties
um unwise or as Philip Schofield might
would say inappropriate but almost
certainly not criminal you know these
expressions of mental torment and mental
uh ill health
um you know any psychiatrist would tell
you they're not unusual they're not
atypical the problem is that he he
wasn't getting constant medical uh
checkups and care where he could
uh talk through uh what was going
through his mind and his emotions uh
with a professional and it's come out in
this way and someone has gone to the Sun
and it's turned into this big issue the
most important thing so if you that we
should remember about this it's been
talked about as a BBC Scandal it is not
a BBC Scandal it so happens that he
works at the BBC in one of the most high
profile uh positions but at the BBC's
fault
they've done nothing wrong other than to
turn this into some kind of uh BBC
investigation issue which was totally
misguided I guess I guess just to put
the alternative point of view there
what some would say is that the BBC has
created this issue because if they had
taken the concerns of the mother and The
Stepfather seriously the regional
complaint they wouldn't have had to go
to the sun if they'd spoken to them if
they'd spoken to you Edwards I guess
look Are you seriously suggesting that
on the basis of a complaint from a
mother and stepfather
rejected by their son as rubbish they
should have suspended Hugh Edwards no
I'm not saying that they could have
talked about anything they could have
spoken to the parties involved they
tried to drive
well look uh
where were they
um and you know there's lots of
questions I'd like to ask the partners
involved how long have you known about
this how do you know about the 35 000
pounds where did all that come from why
haven't you done anything about her
until now where is the actual so-called
victim here uh why are you uh coming to
us and what do you expect us to do see I
don't think it's any job of a
broadcaster to investigate the private
life of its employees if you've got 22
000 employees as the BBC does have there
will be some strange and aberrant and
inappropriate behavior and no doubts and
criminality at times that is not the
BBC's uh issue the BBC should wait and
see what emerges and then if someone
looks to them uh as an employee for help
can I tell three months off can I take
six months off that's an internal HR
matter but you know the notion that the
BBC should be investigating the private
lives of its employees is obnoxious
okay thank you very much for being on
the program this evening and speaking so
forcefully about the statements and the
fallouts from this story thank you thank
you Sophie
well let's remind you now shall we of
our top story this evening the news that
Hugh Edwards has been named as the BBC
presenter at the center of a days long
media frenzy the star who is the highest
paid journalist at the BBC has been
named by his wife in a statement that
she issued on his behalf in the
statement she says that he's suffering
from serious mental health issues and
she's also appealed for privacy for him
and the family
well let's just take you through the
statement now shall we released by his
wife
in like the recent reporting regarding
the BBC presenter I'm making the
statement on behalf of my husband Hugh
Edwards after what have been five
extremely difficult days for our family
I'm doing this primarily out of concern
for his mental well-being and to protect
our children she was suffering from
serious mental health issues as is well
documented he's been treated for severe
depression in recent years the events of
the last few days have greatly worsened
matters who suffered another serious
episode and is now receiving inpatient
hospital care where he'll stay for the
foreseeable future
once well enough to do so he intends to
respond to the stories that have been
published to be clear he was first told
that there were allegations being made
against him last Thursday in the
circumstances and given Hughes condition
I would like to ask that the privacy of
my family and everyone else caught up in
these upsetting events is respected I
know that he was deeply sorry that so
many colleagues have been impacted by
the recent media speculation we hoped
this statement will bring that to an end
that statement there by the wife of Hugh
Edwards naming him as the BBC presenter
who has been suspended in other news
this evening the police have said that
they won't be taking these complaints
any further at this time so we await the
BBC investigation more coming up after
the short break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
to a potential crash so many words so
many meanings but what do they mean for
you and your finances stay up to date on
Sky News I'm Martha Kellner and I'm
Sky's U.S correspondent based here in
Los Angeles it's turning everybody into
a crazy violent drug addict
how are you feeling I am angry are you a
hypocrite sir will your candidates win I
hope so I got to be realistic my
sister's dead
more than four weeks on there's no
murder weapon and no suspect
mum how are you feeling today Jeffrey
said you answered again you just don't
cross her I'm so excited severe
nightmares of these people coming in and
just taking me in the middle of the
night
I've watched as whole towns were torn
apart by natural disaster
I'm alive and I'm thankful for that we
take you to the heart of the stories
which shape our world
a lot of cases that I know are reported
from Ukrainian missiles themselves
Ambassador with respect I think that's
preposterous
[Music]
thank you
all right thank you for that Sophie and
welcome back Josh and Sky News Tonight
our top story Hugh Edwards has been
named as the BBC presenter at the center
of a days long media frenzy the star who
is the highest paid journalist at the
BBC has been named by his wife in a
statement that she issued on his behalf
she says he is suffering from serious
mental health issues and has appealed
for privacy for him and for the family
now in the statement released by his
wife Vicki Lind
in light of the recent reporting
regarding the BBC presenter I am making
this statement on behalf of my husband
Hugh Edwards after what have been five
extremely difficult days for our family
I'm doing this primarily out of concern
for his mental well-being and to protect
our children Hugh is suffering from
serious mental health issues as is well
documented he's been treated for severe
depression in recent years the events of
the last few days have greatly worsened
matters he suffered another serious
episode and is now receiving inpatient
hospital care where he will stay for the
foreseeable future
once well enough to do so he intends to
respond to the stories that have been
published to be clear Hugh was first
told that there were allegations being
made against him last Thursday
in the circumstances and given huge
condition I would like to ask that the
privacy of my family and everyone else
caught up in these upsetting events is
respected
I know that Hugh is deeply sorry that so
many colleagues have been impacted by
the recent media speculation we hope
this statement will bring that to an end
all right let's just remind you now with
how we reach this point now over the
weekend the Sun newspaper claimed that
the presenter paid 35
000 pounds for sexually explicited
images over a three-year period
yesterday it was reported by the BBC
that a second person was sent what was
described as abusive and expletive
filled messages
as a presenter allegedly pressured that
person to meet up now today's edition of
the Sun alleges that the presenter broke
lockdown rules with another individual
in February of 2021.
and today the Sun newspaper has
published more claims from another
individual who says that the presenter
sent them creepy messages on Instagram
when they were 17 containing love heart
emojis and kisses
now the Metropolitan Police say they are
taking no further action against Hugh
Edwards in a statement the force said
that detectives from the Mets specialist
crime command have now concluded their
assessment and have determined there is
no information to indicate that a
criminal offense has been committed
in reaching this decision they've spoken
to a number of parties including the BBC
and the alleged complainant and the
alleged complainants family both via
another police force
there's no further police action they
say as such the mets has advised the BBC
it can continue in its internal
investigation
we are aware they say the media
reporting of further allegations against
the same individual no specific details
or information about these allegations
have been passed to us and therefore
there's no police action at this point
they conclude that should evidence of
criminality or safeguarding issues be
identified at any point we would expect
matters to be referred to the relevant
police force
now our arts and entertainment
correspondent Katie Spencer has been
following this story since it broke and
joins us now uh by phone uh Katie so
Hugh Edward's name has been released by
his wife and we are now told that he is
uh receiving medical care after
suffering another episode so much to
reflect on here Katie I mean
first of all I guess that there is a
duty of care that the BBC have said they
have to one of their star presenters
yeah um throughout this
um throughout everything Tim Davey has
said to uh journalists he has stressed
at all times but protecting
in in keeping protecting the anonymity
of this presenter up until now it has
been about the duty of care they feel
towards an employee and it is perhaps
understandable more now we know that and
we can say that it is Hugh Edwards given
um we know his struggles with mental
health over the years
look in in saying nothing while Hugh
Edwards remained Anonymous this has been
hugely hugely damaging for the
corporation itself it has taken an
absolute battering over its handling of
this over the last few days
as a public service broadcaster as one
of the leading broadcasters in the world
it's held to a higher standard and it's
right and it is understandable given the
abuse scandals the BBC has experienced
over the years that it is scrutinized
when it comes to matters like this over
issues of safeguarding now nobody in any
way is comparing these allegations to to
the abuse scandals of the past
is all about how the BBC has handled
this and it has come under such scrutiny
and being targeted by such vitriol over
the missteps that it appears to have
taken in how it has dealt with
um this these these claims being made
about Hugh Edwards why does naming him
matter well of course Hugh Edwards is
one of the most recognizable faces on
British television anchoring coverage of
major major national events presenting
the BBC's Flagship News at 10 program
one of the highest paid employers uh at
the BBC
nobody is saying you have to be perfect
to be in the public eye that's not what
this is about but for some people in
certain roles particularly within news
roles Behavior matters more than it does
in other roles and Hugh Edwards embodied
BBC values he's been the face uh of
their Nightly News program for the last
20 years we know of course he he his
background and his love of the BBC he
joined as a trainee back in the 80s and
has reached such highs becoming one of
the most recognizable phases of news in
this country
um replacing David dimbleby and the
election coverage so he's so well
respected and so well thought of in four
decades at the corporation covering just
the the biggest stories uh in our recent
history things like the funerals of the
Queen the queen and the Duke of
Edinburgh and of course more recently
the coronation of our new king
it it is hard to see how he will return
to that role uh we know from the
statement that his wife has given that
he intends to respond to the stories
that have been published uh once again
uh and I think that it will uh lessen
the heat certainly from this if he is
able to to talk about what has happened
I mean we we live in different times now
perhaps just an explanation and being
able to tell people his side of the
story is is enough that this won't be
career ending but certainly it's hard to
see how we can go back to that Central
role anchoring
um the the the news at 10.
um it was particularly I think it within
the last 24 hours this new case as well
that it has emerged of him breaking
lockdown rules to visit a young person
that he met through a dating app I think
that's the hypocrisy of that as somebody
who would have been fronting a nightly
news program calling out the likes of
Dominic Cummings for breaking the rules
I think when that allegation emerged it
did become particularly uh important I
think in the eyes of a lot of the media
that his name uh be made public really
because there is that element of the
hypocrisy of saying one thing and doing
another but clearly I think it is an
incredibly
um it's incredibly dignified statement
from his wife that she's put out tonight
and he is an extraordinary broadcaster
and hopefully it will be a a case that
in talking about this
he will be able to resume his career one
would think
Katie Spencer answer the internet
corresponder appreciate that analysis
thank you all right well let's just uh
take a moment now to take a look at what
the weather forecast is saying
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now it is getting very warm in southern
Europe but here it's going to be on the
cool side with unsettled where they're
continuing into next week at least
there'll be rain in some places this
evening but the showers will be fairly
isolated with many places remaining dry
you can expect a few more showers
overnight but they will become mainly
confined to expose Northern Western and
channel coasts the wind in the South
will ease the UK is going to see showers
developing widely again tomorrow morning
turning heavy and thundery but northern
England looks mainly dry while Wales
will see the rain Fade Away Ireland will
see more rain taking over the Southwest
it's going to be a little bit warmer
than it was today but windy for many
now Allen will see outbreaks of rain
spreading to all but the far North
during the afternoon while Scotland and
Northern Ireland will keep a fair few
showers England and Wales will see those
showers mostly dying out Friday will
bring strong winds Coastal Gales and
Rain up from the southwest while the
north can expect rain too
sponsored by Qatar Airways
you are watching Sky News tonight and
still to come more reaction to that news
that Hugh Edwards has been named as the
BBC presenter at the center of days of
media Frenzy
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello there and welcome back now more
reaction to the news that Hugh Edwards
has been named as BBC presenter at the
center of these allegations that have
swirled around the media for the past
few days now Paul konyu is the former
editor of the Sunday Mirror and a former
deputy editor of the Daily Mirror Paul
it's good to have you with us so look
the news broken around six o'clock
um I mean it was always going to come
out wasn't it I mean what do you expect
happens from this point onward
for this story has had so many twists
and turns and obviously
in one sense it's a Pity that this very
candid and moving statement by Hugh
Edward's wife
didn't come out a few days ago when the
story is first emerging it might have
changed the you know the landscape I can
only imagine that was possibly unlegal
advice rather than BBC you know
PR advice on the basis that at one stage
there was these the allegation of of CR
of a criminality dimension to this which
of course the the Met have now dismissed
so it's now back as a BBC issue
um potentially of course uh there could
be legal action by Hugh Edwards and his
voice and his family although I think
they've got other priorities at the
moment because the sun's story did the
original Sun story did actually you know
suggest that it you know that there have
been a 17 year old involved here which
would have been a serious offense under
the 1978 protection of children act well
that's gone by the board now so it's so
it's entirely a matter for the for the
BBC
um where it leaves Hugh Edwards you know
I I don't know because it's very sad
news and obviously he's he's suffering
from a huge mental breakdown of and we
don't know when he went into Hospital
whether it was before the story broke or
coinciding with it that isn't clear at
this stage but the question is what
happens to Hugh Edwards now a huge
figure in the BBC one of its highest
paid broadcasters and the face of you
know News at 10 the coronation the Royal
coverage but credit but the public have
strange attitudes I was involved in a
voting program it was this morning in
which about half the callers said that
it was nobody's business they didn't
want to know who it was and others
suggesting that that they should know
and any any aspect of behavior like this
would be forgetting about criminality
was unacceptable so how the court of
public opinion will view it is will be
will be quite interesting but very
interesting but but the question I asked
myself is can Hugh Edwards possibly come
back to that role because it is fronting
the Premier News Bulletin it is covering
the royal family can incredibly
interview politicians public figures pop
stars about their own conduct when
they're in control in controversies or
they're cool into question I think
that's impossible let's let's pick up on
some of those uh the answer to some of
those questions uh in the next hour I
know you're going to stay with us thank
you very much for being this pork on you
former editor at the mayor you're
watching Sky News and still to come
we're going to be speaking to a former
correspondent from the BBC Michael Cole
as Hugh Edwards is named at the as a
presenter at the center of all of these
allegations
[Music]
I'm Hannah Thomas Peter and I'm Sky's
climate change correspondent
the UK is a world leader
leader
it's part of the Congo based rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of Africa we aim
to be the best and most trusted place
for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me I might be just very
naive but I do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
for the last 30 years we have known how
bad it is I'm not here to apologize I'm
here to fight for the next step
you can see just
just the piles of stuff these the sofas
and people's desks and children's books
and you can see inside this home here
people trying to to sort out their home
it's just been devastating
I think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of this beauty
around us
the future of you and me
thank you
[Music]
hello there and welcome back Q Edwards
has been named as the BBC presenter at
the center of allegations concerning
inappropriate contact with a number of
individuals Edwards is the highest paid
journalist at the BBC and was named by
his wife in a statement that she issued
on his behalf saying he is suffering
from a serious mental health episode the
statement appealed for privacy for him
and for his family I'm joined now by the
former BBC correspondent Michael Cole
and Michael Cole thank you very much for
being with us this evening as a former
BBC employee I imagine that some of your
colleagues will not only be concerned
about Hugh Edwards and his health but
also perhaps a little relief that there
is a something of a signpost of a
closure point for this first part of
this story I'm sure that that's true uh
you're you're right on the money there
um but let's say first of all this is
sad uh a terrible State of Affairs at
every level I mean tonight A man is in
hospital uh
suffering
mental illness and we don't know uh what
his future will be his professional life
is in tatters uh maybe his whole future
is in tatters and the sadness is Redland
in in the message from his wife and we
have to remember that there are more
than there's more than one family
involved in this at least two a young
man whose life has been ruined by the
pernicious drug of crack cocaine and
obviously in a family where he doesn't
appear to be on good terms with his
mother
and uh stepfather but we also have to
remember that only 10 days before this
concerned mother rang the BBC with her
concerns uh Hugh who was staying there
was the lead commentator the voice of
the BBC at the coronation of King
Charles III and uh
that is uh a terrible thing to have
happened because for the corporation he
was their face he was the Richard
dimbleby of this age and as Paul
Conneaut was raising the question uh
what his future does he have a future
well first of all uh and I wish him well
and I'm sure everybody does he's got to
get well and as your program knows
because you deal with it a lot and very
expertly mental health is one of the big
stories of this age and what will decide
a lot of things is how much public
sympathy there is for him and how much
care there's being given to the people
who have suffered as his hands while
he's been undergoing such illnesses as
we don't know about but which are
privately his but are obviously serious
or else the set of circumstances
wouldn't have Arisen as it has no but I
mean I suppose there is something to
take from the fact that the story has
moved on from what we first understood
there to be a criminal element the
police in London and in South Wales both
saying there is nothing for them to
investigate and of course once that
statement had come from the police the
statement from Vicki flind naming Hugh
Edwards came shortly thereafter I wonder
how the BBC itself because I'm looking
at some of the monitors they're
obviously reporting this on on the news
Channel right now I wonder how the BBC
itself is feeling internally now many of
the journalists there knew who was
behind these allegations I wonder how
that organization goes forward from this
point yes well there will be a great
deal of relief that the dam has broken
if you will and that they can begin to
deal with it because I'm afraid in the
past they haven't dealt with this in
situations like this the BBC is
ponderous at an elephantine level and it
should have reacted much earlier Tim
Daly should have been briefed I don't
know where his wingmen were when
somebody makes an allegation about your
top star presenter the face of the see
in such a alleged circumstances vile
circumstances well you would have
thought that the director General would
have been on top of that because the
seriousness of this cannot be
exaggerated and there's plenty of form
I'm afraid to say we've had the Jimmy
Savile case we've had uh Rolf Harris
okay disgraceful for Martin Bashir
episode so they're certainly crisis
yeah but it perhaps explains something
from the statement of Vicki flind that
the health of Hugh Edwards is at stake
here perhaps in some way speaks to the
residents of the BBC but of course that
will come out in in due course Michael
Cole for now thank you very much for
that right plenty more to come on Sky
News Tonight of courts in the next hour
of the program as we'll get more
reaction to this breaking news that Hugh
Edwards a man who's been at the center
of BBC broadcasting for the last 30
years has been named as individual
against which alligators have been made
of inappropriate contact with young men
more on that at the top of the hour
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
this is Sky News Tonight our top story
the wife of the BBC presenter Hugh
Edwards names him as the man at the
center of allegations that have plunged
the corporation into crisis
in a statement Vicky Flynn says that the
BBC star is suffering from serious
mental health issues
the police say no criminal offense has
been committed and that the BBC can now
conclude their own internal
investigation
we'll be live at new Broadcasting House
in central London for the very latest
and will ask former colleague zov Hugh
Edwards what now for the star and for
the corporation
[Music]
good evening our top story Hugh Edwards
has been named as the BBC presenter at
the center of allegations concerning
inappropriate contact with a number of
individuals Edwards is the highest paid
journalist at the BBC and was named
earlier by his wife in a statement that
she issued on his behalf she says that
he is suffering from serious mental
health issues and has appealed for
privacy for him and for the family
well here is that statement from Vicki
flind in full it says in light of the
recent reporting regarding the BBC
presenter I am making this statement on
behalf of my husband Hugh Edwards after
what have been five extremely difficult
days for our family
I'm doing this primarily out of concern
for his mental well-being and to protect
our children Hugh is suffering from
serious mental health issues as is well
documented he's been treated for severe
depression in recent years
the events of the last few days have
greatly worsened matters he suffered
another serious episode and is now
receiving inpatient hospital care where
he will stay for the foreseeable future
once well enough to do so he intends to
respond to the stories that have been
published to be clear Hugh was first
told that there were allegations being
made against him last Thursday
in the circumstances and given his
condition I would like to ask that the
privacy of my family and everyone else
caught up in these upsetting events is
respected
I know that Hugh is deeply sorry that so
many colleagues have been impacted by
the recent media speculation we hope
this statement will bring that to an end
now the naming of Hugh Edwards comes as
the Metropolitan Police say they'll be
taking no further action against the
presenter
the force said detectives from the Mets
specialist crime command have now
concluded their assessment and have
determined there is no information to
indicate that a criminal offense has
been committed
in reaching this decision they have
spoken to a number of parties including
the BBC and the alleged complainant and
the alleged complainants family both via
another police force
there is no further police action as
such the Mets had advised the BBC it can
continue with its internal investigation
we're aware of media reporting of
further allegations against the same
individual no specific details or
information about these allegations have
been passed at us and therefore there is
no police action at this time they
conclude should evidence of criminality
or safeguarding issues be identified at
any point we would expect matters to be
referred to the relevant police force
now our Ashner hurunak is outside new
Broadcasting House in central London and
joins us now live Ashna it's good to
have you with us so look a couple of
hours now since the name of Hugh Edwards
has come out and I guess the postmortem
is exactly what took place now begins
but first
the welfare of who editors whose wife
says he's in hospital must be front of
people's mind
I think that is a really important Point
actually Kamali I mean in the last hour
we've had a number of guests name check
the previous people who have been at the
heart of frenzied stories like this um
what comes to mind is is the presenter
Caroline Flack and many people have
reflected on the fact that this is a man
who clearly is going through quite a a
time of turmoil is dealing with a number
of mental health issues this is somebody
who in the past Hugh Edwards had spoken
about the fact that he is uh he has
lived with some bouts of depression in
the past and that he continues as in the
wife in the words of his wife Vicki
blind is suffering with yet another
episode we know that he is currently in
hospital and has been admitted as an
inpatient
um I have to say though being down here
at the BBC headquarters here in London
looking at the screens that you can just
see beyond the glass doors and the
distance behind me there it is a very
jarring sight Act actually to look at
their their broadcasting and look at
what is being transmitted and see the
face of one of their most senior
colleagues if not the most senior
colleague being talked about in this way
and I I think it has been incredibly
difficult time for absolutely Mr
edwards's family but also his colleagues
too and we've seen in the past a few
days how a number of his colleagues that
he's worked with namely Jerry Vine Rylan
Clark
Gary lineker have faced a torrent of
abuse namely on social media and it has
been a case of trial Balsa by social
media many of these figures say who have
been forced to come out and say this
isn't anything to do with me this is
absolutely tonight the biggest
development in this story this has been
brewing now for over five days and let
us remember we are talking about now uh
the most decorated
um news reader of our time certainly
when it comes to the BBC this is
somebody who has been on air for the
number of their bulletins from the six
o'clock bulletin to the 10 o'clock news
for over 30 years someone who is very
much the voice of a Nation who has been
the commentator of numerous State
occasions and therefore it gives an
Insight I suppose into why this story
has rumbled on for so long yes there has
been a huge amount of public interest
and whilst many people in that building
behind me will have known that name it
will have been very hard for them to
come to terms with them with it but also
very hard for them to report on a story
like this and difficult for broadcasters
too it was not we were in no position to
have uttered Mr edwards's name there is
a huge amount of privacy and defamation
law that comes into this so now this I
suppose his family and his wife feeling
empowered to come out of this statement
and addressing these allegations it is
quite a powerful moment I think and we
heard just before uh Hugh edwards's wife
came out with his name from The
Metropolitan Police saying that there is
no criminal evidence to be found it
therefore does not warrant an
investigation that was relating to the
primary allegation in this story an
allegation that was first reported by
the Sun newspaper where they alleged
that payments totaling of up to 35 000
pounds had been made to a young person
who perhaps was age 17 at the time
allegations which have not been
corroborated as far as
broadcasters but also the police are
able to see as far as the police found
there are no criminal proceedings to be
had there have been a number of
allegations that have come out since but
as they say in their statement unless
they see evidence unless they see
um further proof or proof um in general
they there shont be anything to answer
to Meanwhile of course the BBC will now
be allowed to continue their internal
investigation and that will be where the
questions will lie she wed was his
statement on on his behalf put out by
his wife said that he did not learn of
these allegations until Thursday seven
weeks after they were allegedly made by
the alleged victims family so now
attention will turn to the corporation
behind me because at the very heart of
this the face of their credibility the
face of their Authority he has been
suspended from this organization yeah
our national as you rightly points out
the police the Metropolitan Police and
South Wales police have both said they
are not going to be pursuing any
criminal investigation at this stage
into this so no criminality involved as
we understand it at this point but it's
about his personality isn't it it's
about the person that people allow into
their homes every night and on those
huge occasions as we look at Hugh Ed was
presenting some of the biggest set
pieces for the BBC and the question then
begins to be asked can this man return
to our screens
to be really truthful it is probably
quite um too it's too soon to to really
say say where
um Hugh Edwards will return to the
running orders is he going to continue
in that high profile role or is he going
to step back into a more Junior position
perhaps but you're right this is
somebody who is hugely trusted as I say
a face of credibility a face of
authority he is commentated on Prince
William's wedding Prince Harry's wedding
the the funeral of Queen Elizabeth II
and also the coronation of King Charles
most recently there will absolutely be
questions for where he fits back into
the fold but for the moment real
questions over the BB's internal
investigate BBC's internal investigation
and where they go next yep and that
internal investigation will be
continuing Ashner for now appreciate
that thank you so much now let's bring
in the media commentator Nigel Paulie
who's joining us now live Nigel's good
to have you with us so look Ashton has
given us the news element of this but I
want you to try and analyze what you
have seen over the past few days and put
that in light of what we learned this
evening and what we heard from uh Vicki
Flint the wife of Hugh Edwards
well it's a tragedy around it's been a
tragedy unfolding over the past week uh
tragic for the people involved tragic
for Vicki Flynn and whoever's five
children
um who have obviously had huge pressures
and will face huge pressures going
forward so no one is really happy about
this and this will be a huge shock
although the name has been touted on
social media
Hugh Edwards is the face of BBC News he
did announce the Queen's death he did
Cover State occasions people take
viewers take people like Hugh Edwards as
a friend they think they know him they
think they trust him they think that he
is their friend because he is always
there in the corner of their from room
as they watch the television so I'm sure
a lot of people will be hugely shocked
by the not only the allegations but by
the state of his mental health at the
moment who's obviously a very very ill
man he the erratic Behavior obviously
dates back three years as well because
that's when this first started so there
have been issues that he suffered it's
going to be a shock to viewers but it's
not about personalities now I think he
needs to be left to recover and I think
his family and the victim that you know
that everyone is a victim in this the
the the the the person at the beginning
who was involved in the allegations his
family has has a rift now as as well no
one has come out well the spotlight now
will return to the BBC and the Sun and
both of those because the BBC on how
much they knew how much they
investigated the fact is your
correspondence said that Q Webb was only
knew about this on Thursday when plate
was made seven weeks ago Worldcom was a
shock I think the BBC have questions to
answer the spotlight will go heavily on
the sun because they were the paper that
broke this story
sorry to interrupt you then in full film
we haven't got some breaking news that's
coming to the Sun have in the last few
minutes issued a statement surrounding
this let me just read this to our
viewers and then you can react off the
back of that Nigel the sun say they have
no plans to publish further allegations
about Hugh Edwards and we'll cooperate
with the BBC's internal investigation
process as a spokesperson for the
newspaper so no plans to publish any
further allegations past few days have
been all from pages about this haven't
they of course and they're going to
cooperate with the BBC's internal
investigation I suppose that's telling
because of course when these allegations
first broke in the Sun newspaper there
was a suggestion of criminality that
police have said there is no criminality
involved so unless I guess that speaks
to your point that as we look ahead for
the next few days these organize and
let's deal with the sun first of all
again I have to sort of look at the way
that these past few days have been uh
reported and handled
the spotlight is gonna be on the sun I'm
sure they're lawyers they they were
pretty pleaded public interest defense
that this was in the public interest and
I think that will be looked at now but
that statement to me says the sun are
raining back on this because they know
that a much-loved presenter is suffering
a mental health breakdown
on the top of coverage that they started
a week ago that is not a very good
position for a newspaper to be in they
will be worried that you you mentioned
Caroline Flack earlier there is a lot
things have changed over the over the
last few years in privacy issues and the
newspaper now has put the stuff out
there it is played its best card it is
given its best shot at this story and
the story is crumbling as it was
originally sold there is no illegality
uh the the guy at the center of it has
now his name is out and there's a lot of
sympathy for him because of his mental
health issues therefore the sun cannot
go on further with this story because
they're kicking someone who's very much
down and is not able to have his right
reply either so now the BBC will
continue to investigate I would imagine
they will come up with some sort of
report when uh who Edwards is well
enough to uh cope with whatever response
on that you mentioned mentioned earlier
will he come back from this
he may he may possibly it it depends on
what the BBC report says but it could be
that the age of 61 BBC used to have
retire people at 60 he may well take a
health reason out of the BBC who knows
but the moment he used to get well and
his family needs to be left alone
yeah I think most people watching will
agree with with that pool for now Nigel
Nigel poorly do appreciate your analysis
Let's uh go back to New broadcasting
house and bring Ashner back here and and
Ashner just pick up for as if you can on
that latest statement that we've had
from the Sun newspaper uh and uh their
decision as to how they are going to be
reporting this story for the next few
days
yeah this is as your guest just
mentioned that Kamali it appears to be a
raining back in uh from some of that
reporting over the last a few days in
light of what we know now so we've had
an extended uh statement from a
spokesperson on behalf of the sun who
they say the allegations published in
the Sun newspaper were always very
serious further serious allegations have
emerged in the past few days it is right
they say that the BBC's corporate
investigations team continues to
investigate these thoroughly and deals
with them in a way they think is
appropriate the sun will cooperate with
the BBC's internal investigation process
we will provide the BBC team with a
confidential and redacted dossier
containing serious and wide-ranging
allegations which we have received
including some from BBC Personnel the
sun has no plans to publish further
allegations we must also re-emphasize
that the Sun at no point in our original
story alleged criminality and also took
the decision neither to name Mr Edwards
nor the young person involved in the
allegations suggestions this statement
from the Sun newspaper goes on to say
suggestions about possible criminality
were first made at a later date by other
media Outlets including the BBC from the
outset we've reported a story about two
very concerned of frustrated parents who
made a complaint to the BBC about the
behavior of a presenter and payments
from him that fueled the drug habit of a
young person we reported that the
parents had already been to the police
who said that they couldn't help the
parents then made a complaint to the BBC
which was not at Dupont upon it is now
for the BBC to properly investigate so a
lengthy statement there from the Sun
newspaper reacting to what we now know
and the statement issued by Vicki Flynn
the wife of the BBC News presenter Hugh
Edwards and the son saying there they
are now going to work with the BBC's
investigations team to look over and
investigate their these matters it's
interesting in this statement that they
reference the fact that they will hand
over
unredacted information that they have
collated before publishing this story
which they say contains serious and
wide-ranging allegations which we have
received including they reference some
BBC members of Staff
um but it is clear though that they
emphasize at this at this point they are
not going to report any further stories
relating to Mr Edwards and it's
interesting also within this statement
is they re-emphasize the fact that they
didn't in the original publishing of
that article say there had been any form
of criminality but it is now they say
with the BBC's investigations team and
their matter a matter for them to
investigate but they do say the
newspaper that they are now willing to
work with them
thank you for reading that statement in
full it is lengthy and it is fascinating
because many people who've been
following this story for the past few
days will perhaps look at that line at
no point in our original story did we
allege criminality and think well the
influence of criminality was there the
dots may not have been put together by
the Sun and that uh uh reading of the uh
the code the the uh the law that may
well have been broken that 1978 law
about soliciting uh pictures from from a
person under the age of 18 May well not
have been in the original son's story
but the inference was certainly there so
fascinating to see that now at this
stage the Sun newspaper have decided to
row back from that and I do wonder what
kind of cooperation they're going to
offer to the BBC when uh for the past
few days many people have been asking
for the sun to publish some of the
evidence that they've been holding from
that original allegation
and people were wondering you know where
are these alleged bank statements uh you
know there are programs which you can
illustrate such evidence if you have it
and people were questioning very early
on how watertight was the evidence that
they had
um and if you go back and do read that
original story it was very carefully
worded a lot of mentions of these were
accusations these were allegations and
clearly very clearly and making an
effort not to mention uh or any
identifying features of this presenter
at the heart of it there will be
questions about how watertight and how
robust that information was and how
confident they were in publishing it it
but I think there will be questions now
for
um I suppose what this relationship and
what evidence they will bring and have
with the BBC's investigations team so I
think there will be a lot of scrutiny
over the handling over the last few days
I think you're right fashion all right
for now Ashley new broadcasting house to
appreciate that all right you're
watching uh Sky News tonight and still
to come we're going to have plenty more
reaction to the news of Hugh Edwards
being named as the presenter at the
center of the scandals surrounding the
BBC
advice
foreign
[Applause]
to a potential crash so many words so
many meanings but what do they mean for
you and your finances stay up to date on
Sky News I'm Martha Kellner and I'm
Sky's U.S correspondent based here in
Los Angeles it's turning everybody into
a crazy violent drug addict
how are you feeling I am angry are you a
hypocrite sir will your candidates win I
hope so I got to be realistic my
sister's dead
more than four weeks on there's no
murder weapon and no suspect
mum how are you feeling today Jeffrey
said you answered again you just don't
cross her you're so excited severe
nightmares of these people coming in and
just
just in the middle of the night
I've watched as whole towns were torn
apart by natural disaster I'm alive and
I'm thankful for that we take you to the
heart of the stories which shape our
world
a lot of cases that I know are reported
from Ukrainian missiles themselves
ambassador
[Music]
foreign
welcome back now after almost a week of
intense speculation the BBC newsreader
Hugh Edwards has been named as the man
accused of paying a teenager for
explicit photographs his wife Vicky
Flint issued a statement on Ms Edward's
behalf saying he is seriously ill in
hospital this is the statement from Hugh
Edward's wife in full and it reads in
light of the recent reporting regarding
the BBC presenter I am making this
statement on behalf of my husband Hugh
Edwards after what have been five
extremely difficult days for our family
I am doing this primarily out of a
concern to his mental well-being and to
protect our children Hugh is suffering
from serious mental health issues as is
well documented he's been treated for
severe depression in recent years the
events of the last few days have greatly
worsened matters he has suffered another
serious episode and is now receiving
inpatient hospital care where he'll stay
for the foreseeable future
once well enough to do so he intends to
respond to the stories that have been
published to be clear Q was first told
that there were allegations against him
uh being made against him sorry last
Thursday in these circumstances and
given Hugh's condition I would like to
ask that the privacy of my family and
everyone else caught up in these
upsetting events is respected I know
that he was deeply sorry that so many
colleagues have been impacted by the
recent media speculation we hope this
statement will bring that to an end
well in the last few minutes a
spokesperson for the Sun the newspaper
that brought about these allegations
have released a statement let's take you
through that in full and it reads the
allegations published by the sun were
very serious further serious allegations
have emerged in the past few days it is
right that the BBC's corporate
investigations team continues to
investigate these thoroughly and deals
with them in the way that they think is
appropriate the sun will cooperate with
the BBC's internal investigation process
we will provide the BBC team with a
confidential and redacted dossier
containing serious and wide-raging
allegations which we have received
including some from BBC personnel
the sun has no plans to publish further
allegations we must also re-emphasize
that the Sun at no point in our original
story alleged criminality and also took
the decision neither to name Mr Edwards
nor the young person involved in the
allegations
suggestions about possible criminality
were first made at a later date by other
media Outlets including the BBC
from the outset we have reported a story
about two very concerned and frustrated
parents who made a complaint to the BBC
about the behavior of a presenter and
payments from him that fueled the drug
habit of a young person we reported that
the parents had already been to the
police who said that they couldn't help
the parents then made a complaint to the
BBC which was not acted upon it's now
for the BBC to properly investigate all
right let's bring back in Paul konyu
former editor of the Sunday Mirror and
former deputy editor at the sun's former
sister newspaper the news of the world
Paul uh good to have you uh with us
still let's just pick up on some of the
points that have been raised in that sun
statement and first of all
give me your thoughts on when they say
that at no point in their original story
did they allege criminality and it was
other media Outlets that started to
allege that criminality and the
criminality they're talking about is the
uh offense under the protection of of a
child act 1978 to uh solicits a pitch
from someone under the age of 18. I
think both the BBC and the sun are still
going to have some serious questions to
answer
um I haven't got in front of me the
original son the story but certainly
there was an inference there because the
age of 17 was mentioned which as you've
just said well
would constitute an offense under the
inflict of children act 1978 which
carries a very stiff prison sentence so
I'm not quite sure I mean this obviously
a very carefully crafted legal statement
but you know by by the Sun and and it'd
be interesting to see precisely what the
cooperation level with the BBC
investigation will be but the BBC
continued to have questions to answer
about how that how they handled it
um and these aren't going these aren't
going to go away
um I also wonder whether when the before
the sun broke the story did they
actually go to the Edwards family and
and on did they at all were they made
aware In fairness to the sun were they
made aware of the mental health issues
and if they it and would they if they'd
been told that and as I say if would it
have influenced the way the story was
handled or carried at all so I mean but
of course there are other allegations
which are non criminal nature the son of
ronin from from other alleged contacts
of of Hugh Edwards we in and their
claims which of course will need to be
investigated by the BBC investigation
because you know some of those the
public have changing social mores some
people will say it's it's totally is
private life and none of our business
others will see it as a total it's
unacceptable and so and totally
compromising him as the face of of BBC
News and role coverage so so it's it's
still not going to go away in that away
in that in that sense even though the
sun quite rightly in my mind we decided
not to run any more allegations we don't
know even if they had any but there but
I think out of sensitivity then they're
not going to run anymore
um but I suppose Paul I suppose the
point the point about whether or not you
Edwards comes back on TV is one to be
decided in in the weeks and perhaps
months that come ahead but you know
sticking with the sort of the
investigations that's going on because
obviously the BBC are going to run their
own and the sun say they're going to
cooperate but it is interesting in this
sun statement they say they're going to
provide a redacted dossier with a
serious and wide raging allegations and
here's the The Clincher for me in this
sentence including some from BBC
Personnel so even as they issue this
statement sort of
um ceasing fire they're still laying out
that they have some
um evidence something else that they
perhaps could be publishing
that's certainly it could be read that
way most certainly and and also you
question you know how redacted does it
does redacted mean in the you know in in
this case
um
I mean but for the on the BBC's part of
course I mean I'm the attitude was
legally thwarted from exposing Jimmy
Savile back in 1994 and after that
another and other scandals the BBC
publicly pledged that they put in tough
red flag internal warnings an
investigation systems in place but they
they've certainly failed in this one in
terms of of how this has been handled
and the pace up which it's been handled
now we don't know the strength of
the sun's reports in terms of exactly
what Hugh Edwards did or didn't do or
you know obviously something some things
happen that's that's absolutely no
denial of the exchanging of money that
has there in the statement from Hugh
Edward's wife as well you would expect
if that was complete fabrication that
might well have been in the statement
from the family you're absolutely right
I mean it's yeah I think it's it's very
probable or I can't I can't say for sure
but I think it's very probable money
money was transferred
um the the question the question is I
suppose to a extent do do the son you
know the Senate said they have a dossier
he now presumably that may contain proof
of of of payments then of course there's
the other Claim about about another
individual and who it was break breaking
lockdown rules to visit someone so so
all of all of these uh it's very complex
it's when it swings around woman's
crazily but as I say I think the BBC
still have many questions to answer
about the way they handled or mishandled
this and the son have questions to
answer about about how they had they
handled it too
um I I suspect that sometime probably
not after the summer recess the commons
media select committee
will be having one of their meetings on
this one calling everybody before it and
then issuing issuing a report and uh
that may well at least have some
influence on Hugh Edwards future
although I suspect that that from the
statement I suspect that Hugh Edwards
probably
and his family don't really expect him
to be coming back to the BBC not
certainly not in not in the role that
he's he's failed for the last 20 odd
years
yeah perhaps not in there the BBC will
perhaps have to strengthen some of those
measures they brought in as you rightly
point out after you're reporting around
the southern Affair pork on you really
appreciate your expertise on this
particular subject stay with us thank
you very much because you are watching
Sky News tonight and still to come I'm
going to be speaking to John Sargent the
journalist and former colleague of Hugh
Edwards
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ERS tonight our top stories this evening
the BBC news reader Hugh Edwards has
been named as the man at the center of a
scandal which has engulfed the
corporation
his wife Vicky flind released a
statement on his behalf saying he's in
hospital being treated for serious
mental health issues
hewitters was identified after the
Metropolitan Police said they had
concluded their investigation found no
evidence of criminality
[Music]
let's bring back in our correspondent
Ashner uranank who's outside new
Broadcasting House the BBC headquarters
in central London and Ashna the director
General Tim Davey who we saw being
interviewed on the BBC Radio Show
Yesterday by Sarah Montague has now sent
a message to staff what's he had to say
yeah this is an internal email that's
been sent to all members of staff at the
BBC and it reads in a message this will
no doubt be a difficult time for many
after a challenging few days the
director General says I want to reassure
you that our immediate concern is our
duty of care to all involved it's likely
we're going to hear a more Fuller
statement from the BBC from the
corporation in the coming few minutes
but that message there sent by the
director General Tim Davey who yesterday
as you mentioned Kamali not only faced
uh questions from its own Corporation
but also had to answer questions
following the BBC's annual report in
which it focused very heavily on funding
and what I suppose is it's quite an
interesting turn of events actually
mention the fact that it had some of its
highest paid members of staff are on a
list of which Hugh Edwards was named the
fourth highest paid member of Staff
within the BBC and the highest paid new
news reader given his seniority we've
mentioned it before with this within
this hour but this is someone who is so
iconic to many millions of people a
voice of a Nation for a multiple
occasions whether it be Prince Harry or
Prince William's wedding the funeral of
Queen Elizabeth the coronation most
recently of King Charles and only the
last month last couple of months was
narrating the trooping of the color but
that message there from Tim Davey to in
in an internal message to staff members
at the BBC reading that duty of care is
with all concerned I want to bring you
further elements of that statement of
that letter that has been or emailed
that has been sent to BBC staff members
in the last few minutes I wanted to
write writes Mr Davey following this
evening's statements from the family of
Hugh Edwards and the police many of you
will have read the words of Vicki Flynn
Hugh's wife it is a reminder that the
last few days have seen personalized
played out in public at the heart of
this are people and their families this
will no doubt be a difficult time for
many after a challenging few days I want
to reassure you that our immediate
concern is our duty of care to all
involved also this afternoon the
directorate general of the BBC goes on
to say the Metropolitan Police and South
Wales police confirmed they would be
taking no further action following an
assessment of information provided to
them as you know we were asked to pause
our fact-finding investigations until
that assessment has been concluded is it
is important that we now continue with
this work I want to be clear that in
doing so we will follow due process he
finally ends with this remains a very
complex set of circumstances as we have
done throughout our a must be to
navigate through this with care and
consideration in line with the BBC
values that is statement and in the last
few minutes that was sent to the inboxes
of BBC staff responding to what we now
know this evening that Hugh Edwards is
the suspended presenter at the heart of
these allegations
okay Ashner for now thank you so much
for the National Hurricane reporting
from new broadcasting house let's bring
in now John Sargent the BBC's former
Chief political correspondent and a
friend and colleague of Hugh Edwards
John Sergeant thank you so much for
being with us this evening in what might
be a really trying time not just for you
of course but for his family and those
that know him well
tell us about you the man
well when I first heard a few days ago
that it was likely to be you it was
going to be the suspect I was just
completely taken aback I've known him
for more than 30 years as a friend and a
colleague as a witty friend as a funny
friend there's a someone to spend a lot
of time with we did spend a lot of time
together we were political
correspondence together that famous
incident involving Margaret Thatcher and
me outside the British Embassy I was
doing the television version who was
doing the radio version Hugh Edwards so
you can imagine the shock to me
personally I'm told he is the suspect an
awful sinking feeling of oh no this
isn't the Hue that I knew and that's
that's still my Sensational feeling
about it and I'm very pleased the
director General Tim Davey is now
talking about the duty of
friend he clearly needs a lot of looking
after
yeah and that YouTube care I guess would
explain uh why there's been some
criticism with the BBC and it's sort of
openness about this but I guess it's
explained somewhat by the statement that
we've heard from from Vicky flind and
you say that when you heard the
allegations it wasn't the Hue that you
recognized were there anything in the
allegations that you saw as being the
Hugh Edward was that you knew it was
just so out of anything that you
expected to come from from a friend of
yours
oh yeah because you know whatever else
Hugh knows about he knows about the news
business he knows about politics and the
idea that you would ring people up you
would endanger your career to the extent
to which these allegations endlessly
referred to what he had done or was said
to have done or that he'd used foul
language that he'd threatened people
none of that seems to be and seemed to
me just sensible so once we're told that
he's suffering from serious mental
illness I must say I then think oh right
now we're beginning to get a bit of
sense into all this we now know what the
sort of General position is about you
instead of him saying oh we don't know
and he's not saying anything and the
director General can't tell us does he
plead guilty or not guilty as he's
saying he's innocent none of those
things now uh so much the four simply
because we're told he's an inpatient in
a mental award so you know that means
the gloves should be off and they should
be now this doesn't mean to say that the
whole thing is all over and that nothing
has to be decide nothing has to be
inquired into but the immediate crisis
the hour by hour what's going to happen
next I hope now will come to an end yeah
well that remains to be seen doesn't it
John Sergeant the Sun have said they're
not going to be publishing any more
allegations but cryptically within their
statements saying they do still hold
some information that they're going to
share with the BBC what you seem to be
suggesting is that perhaps some of the
behavior or the allegations of behavior
May well have been because
um he was was unwell and that's I guess
is supported by some of the statement
that has come from his from his wife
Vicki flind well that's where it's one
of the key is saying and if she says
he's impatient uh you know he's
impatient in the hospital well I mean
you certainly can't say oh I'm not sure
I believe that and the sun are right to
then think okay for the moment we row in
with the BBC investigation and meaning
really throttle backs folks you know
this has been an amazing sort of media
frenzy and you can't go on and on when
there's someone in fact who is it may be
dangerously ill and we don't know this
but we see so certainly as I say from my
point of view I just think oh come on
you uh uh what can I what can we do to
help now this doesn't mean as I say let
me stress this it doesn't mean to say oh
so that's it so nothing wrong has
happened nobody's made any mistakes no
people have made mistakes this has been
extremely serious and it's more serious
from now on because we know there will
be more and more fake claims of people
saying things and doing things because
of all the skill of artificial
intelligence and and fake news stories
so this is something we all have to live
with in one way or another and we also
have to live with the real dangers of
mental health and principle
mental health but look what happens when
there's a real crisis are we all Frank
and open and just say oh yes this is
just like an ordinary illness it's not
like an ordinary illness it's more
difficult to cope with it's more
embarrassing and it requires much more
care compassion and above all
understanding yeah and if something does
come out of this I guess that that would
be um
something to take that there perhaps
will be a better understanding and more
time taken to try and understand the
full context of stories before as you
say media frenzies begin but that said
the BBC perhaps will have some questions
to answer and the Sun as well in the
coming days and weeks in terms of how
they dealt with it because there was a
long time period before what I think we
can accept was it was a fairly serious
allegation at the very beginning no
criminality but still a serious
allegation about a major star that was
left that was left unanswered for a
number of weeks well parents of a person
who were very concerned about their
young person and their health uh will
have to wonder what was happening going
no I agree all those are extremely
pertinent and serious issues they've got
to be considered what what action was
taken where the BBC rights simply to
email and to make a phone call that
didn't get through was that enough to
delay the process clearly something sort
of odd and strange and difficult was
happening they should have taken it more
seriously I've now no doubt about that
they should have said oh this isn't IQ
we can just check we can look into that
it doesn't seem to be right and they
would have perhaps got to the answer
much more quickly if they hadn't hidden
behind this sort of idea of oh well all
our processes were this and we did that
and so on no somebody in fact with much
more common sense and knowledge should
have moved much more quickly at the
beginning
yeah interesting that BBC May well have
been failing both their employee and the
person who made the allegations by not
acting quickly enough John Sargent do
appreciate your thoughts uh this evening
thank you very much for being with us
John sergeant and their former Chief
political correspondent of the BBC and a
friend of Hugh Edwards now you are
watching Sky News tonight and still to
come we'll have more reaction to the
news that Hugh Edwards has been named as
the presenter of a scandal that has a
affected the BBC for the past few days
foreign
Thomas Peter and I'm Sky's climate
change correspondent
the UK is a world leader in wind power
[Music]
it's part of the Congo based at Ray
Forest which is such an important
ecosystem it's known as the lungs of
Africa we aim to be the best and most
trusted place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me I might be just very
naive but I do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
for the last 30 years we have known how
bad it is I'm not here to apologize I'm
here to fight for the next step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these the sofas and people's desks
and children's books and you can see
inside this home here people trying to
uh to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
I think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of the beauty
around us
the future of you and me
thank you
[Music]
do you know what kind of pollen gets up
your nose
Sky News pollen reports brought to you
by the kleenex your pollen Pal app
parts of the UK will see rain again
tomorrow morning some of it will be
heavy and thundery but northern England
looks mainly dry Ireland will see more
General rain taking over the Southwest
it's going to be windy in many places
the rain over Island will take over the
North during the afternoon while
Scotland and Northern Ireland will keep
a fair few showers England and Wales
will see those showers mostly dying out
the unsettled conditions mean pollen
counts will be moderate for most rising
to high in parts of the drier East
Sky News pollen reports brought to you
by the kleenex your pollen Pal app
welcome back now the BBC newsreader Hugh
Edwards is seriously in a hospital after
suffering a relapse with his mental
health he's been named as the presenter
at the center of allegations published
in the Sun newspaper that he paid a
teenager for explicit photographs the
police have been investigating and say
there is no evidence that a criminal
offense has been committed now the Sun
have released a lengthy statement in the
last hour and it reads the allegations
published by the sun were always very
serious further serious allegations have
emerged in the past few days it is right
that the BBC's corporate investigations
team continues to investigate these
thoroughly and deals with them in the
way that they think is appropriate the
sun will cooperate with the BBC's
internal investigation process we will
provide the BBC team with a confidential
and redacted dossier containing serious
and wide-ranging allegations which we
have received including some from BBC
personnel the sun has no plans to
publish further allegations we must also
re-emphasize that the Sun at no point in
our original story alleged criminality
and also took the decision neither to
name Mr Edwards nor the young person
involved in the allegations
suggestions about possible criminality
were first made at a later date by other
media Outlets including the BBC
from the outset we have reported the
story about two very concerned and
frustrated parents who made a complaint
to the BBC about the behavior of a
presenter and payments from him that
fueled the drug habit of a young person
we reported that the parents had already
been in to the police who said they
couldn't help the parents then made a
complaint to the BBC which was not acted
upon it's now for the BBC to properly
investigate the sun's lengthy statement
there in the past hour Let's uh bring in
now David Banks who's a media law
consultant David Banks thanks very much
for being with us I mean you will have
seen the sun statement there just pick
up on that line that's in the statement
that they say that at no point in their
original story did they talk about uh
alleged criminality there was an
inference of it though wasn't there and
I think
that's that's kind of central to the
public interest of the story because if
you if you haven't got that information
of something that might possibly be
serious enough to be criminal then you
you are
um then purely doing a story about
um something which is much more private
it's only the possible criminality
really that that pushes it into possibly
being a matter of public interest and
that's why the Metropolitan Police
statement today was so interesting that
they have very quickly you've got to say
for you know given the nature of the
allegations they are very quickly
established no evidence of any
criminality further action to be taken
well it would have taken them very long
to work out when the pictures if the
pictures were sent and at what date and
what age the people involved were and
it's interesting that you say that that
you know that the allegation or the
influence of criminality is what kind of
is the public interest defense if you
were advising the the journalists who
were publishing the original
story without that allegation would you
still advise them to publish it because
it's a private matter
I'm quite risk-averse so personally I
would be wanting to see ex I wanted to
see a lot more evidence than we saw
published in the Sun and there were lots
of things that were I thought were
missing there may be reasons why they
were missing but there were things that
I would normally expect a paper if they
had them in their hands to publish
things like redacted bank statements
redacted photographs timelines things
like this proofs of dates and stuff like
that and we weren't seeing that and so
I would be asking questions now I'm sure
that the very professional legal teams
on the sun were asking those questions
as well
but obviously a decision has been making
to go with the story as it as it was
yeah and as the sun falls the next few
days I'm sure those kind of questions
will be asked and perhaps more will come
to light about that just just staying
with with the statement and you
mentioned sort of the publication of
redacted bank statements or something to
to back up some of the evidence
um the son has said in their statement
that they will provide redact to the
dossiers containing series and wide
reading allegations to the BBC to help
with their investigation as and as I
mentioned to one of our contributors
earlier as they sort of stop publishing
allegations about Hewitt was they sort
of keep in advance that they've got more
allegations that they could publish
well yeah and I thought
that's not that's an odd line I thought
an odd line for them to publish in the
statements so saying we're not going to
publish anything more but we've got more
um and in situations like this this it's
kind of inevitable these things happen
we've seen it with other people who were
innocent and accused of things and then
people from their past come out of the
woodwork saying all sorts of stuff about
them not none of us are perfect we've
all got we've all got failings and
sometimes this kind of publicity gives
people an opportunity to have a thing so
we really don't know what that content
is and I guess the BBC will have to sift
through it and see how serious it is
whether it contributes to their inquiry
or whether it is inconsequential yeah
and as as you mentioned earlier of
course the the police are saying no
criminality uh is involved in any of
this and it's worth remembering I mean
so much has happened in the past few
days that the person the center of the
first allegations came out with their
own statement from their lawyers saying
that nothing untoward had happened I
mean
I don't want to make get you to make
predictions as to where this goes from
here but I guess that serious questions
need to be asked by about those the BBC
and the Sun going forward about this
reporting
I think so I think I mean you know it
may well be the Sun have you know the
explanations for all the students they
took editorially I think that
all of us in in media need to consider
now what happens when we do a story that
hints at something in the knowledge that
social media will yeah and and I think
that's something we have to think about
as a society about the way in which
social media will will okay David
yeah you're exactly right it is a moment
for us all to pause and think about the
way that this story has been reported
David Banks you appreciate your your
analysis this evening thank you very
much for that you're watching skony's
more to come in the next hour more
analysis on the news who Edwards has
been named at the BBC presenter at the
center of this process